y empezamos nuestro segmento especial
camino a la casa blanca el espacio
semanal para seguir la contienda entre
el presidente de donald trump y el
candidato demócrata joe biden de cara a
las elecciones presidenciales del 3 de
noviembre hoy vamos a hablar del debate
alrededor del primer debate entre los
candidatos
griterías insultos e interrupciones
marcaron el que ha sido calificado como
el peor cara a cara entre candidatos de
la historia de eeuu
el caos llevó a la comisión de debates
presidenciales un grupo no partidista
que organiza los encuentros desde 1988 a
anunciar cambios en el formato para
garantizar que los próximos encuentros
se realicen de manera ordenada vamos a
hablar en nueva york' con nuestra
corresponsal mamen sala también empiezo
por preguntarte cuál es la influencia
histórica que han tenido los debates en
el voto de los estadounidenses
si a natalia pues desde luego estos
debates son importantes aunque sí que es
cierto que a estas alturas y con la
situación atípica que se vive por esta
pandemia la mayoría de estadounidenses
ya han decidido cuál es su candidato
favorito pero todavía queda un 10% de
indecisos y precisamente así
hacia ese 10% se pretendía dirigir estos
dos candidatos más allá de que luego el
debate se complicará históricamente los
debates han sido muy importantes primero
porque nos permiten ver a los candidatos
en su estado natural segundo porque en
principio salvo lo que vimos este martes
permite a los ciudadanos ver un poco
cuáles van a ser sus propuestas en caso
de que lleguen o se mantengan en la
casablanca y lo hemos visto
históricamente lo vimos ya por ejemplo
en el primer debate televisivo que tuvo
lugar que fue cuando jhon kennedy y ganó
en ese debate a un nixon que llegó pues
enfermo con fiebre que además se había
olvidado de afeitar y que desde luego le
dio muchos motivos a su contrincante
para ganarlo lo vimos también con
bush padré cuando en ese debate
televisado- también miraba a la hora y
los votantes lo interpretaron como que
se estaba aburriendo y tampoco le
permitió llegar a su victoria así que
estos debates son fundamentales y muy
importantes porque la imagen y la
actitud de los candidatos también dice
mucho a los votantes pero desde luego
nada que ver con lo que vimos este
martes que se salió completamente de las
reglas y de cualquier papel de lo que
habíamos visto hasta ahora
y mamen y cuáles son estas
reglamentaciones que la comisión de los
debates presidenciales podría cambiar
para organizar que el intercambio de
ideas sea mejor
si la comisión de debates ha dejado
claro que desde luego no está dispuesto
a que el espectáculo de gritos
enfrentamientos y tiranteces que vimos
el martes se repita por un lado tenemos
al candidato demócrata joe biden que ya
ha dicho que lo que vimos este martes
fue una auténtica vergüenza nacional y
por otro lado tenemos al equipo de
campaña de donald trump que insiste en
que cualquier cambio en las reglas del
debate no es bueno y en la comisión de
debates hace oídos sordos a lo que pide
el presidente y está dispuesto a cambiar
como dices las reglas del juego estas
reglas todavía están se están decidiendo
cómo se van a implementar pero de
momento hemos conocido que lo que sí que
se va a hacer seguramente es cortar los
micrófonos y los candidatos no respetan
sus turnos es algo que como digo veremos
y se confirmará en los próximos días
pero desde luego en los debates del 15 y
del 22 de octubre vamos a ver unas
reglas diferentes a ese a ese caos que
vivimos el pasado martes
amén y podríamos decir entonces que el
debate en general es el gran perdedor
el debate en general es el gran perdedor
yo más bien diría que son los propios
estadounidenses los que perdieron porque
fue imposible entender nada entre tanto
grito e interrupción y esas peleas y
golpes bajos que vimos para que os
hagáis una idea si normal si el año 2016
hubo 84 millones de estadounidenses que
siguieron el primer debate este año
muchos apagaron su televisor y tan solo
28 7 millones de estadounidenses
siguieron este primer debate por hacer
algún tipo de lectura positiva lo que sí
que pudimos ver en ese debate es un
reflejo de cómo está la sociedad
estadounidense en este momento
tremendamente polarizada y desde luego
con mucha tensión después de 8 meses ya
de pandemia como dices ninguno de los
dos tuvo la oportunidad de dejar claro
cuál era su programa y la verdad es que
fue terrible que esos gritos y esos
enfrentamientos dejarán en segundo plano
cuestiones tan importantes como cuál va
a ser el futuro de la corte suprema- qué
va a pasar con la situación económica
desastrosa que vive el país en estos
momentos cómo se va a gestionar
pandemia y varios temas más que por
supuesto pues quedaron un poco
desdibujados en medio de tanto
enfrentamiento insultos golpes bajos y a
gritos y bueno y fue imposible seguir el
hilo de lo que cada uno de los
candidatos quería poner encima de la
mesa en caso de que llegara la casa
blanca por parte del parte del candidato
demócrata o que se mantuviera en ella
por parte del presidente donald trump en
nueva york' gracias a nuestra
corresponsal mamen sala por participar
en este segmento especial de aquí
américa camino a la casa blanca y
ustedes gracias por acompañarme en esta
emisión recuerden que pueden seguirme en
redes sociales en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas cuídense mucho del
coronavirus y sigan viendo france24